Billy are there moments that no one
knows about we're like you got together
with let's say I don't know who Eric
Clapton or you got together with the
Beatles or you got together with
somebody like a session happened late at
night where you all got together in
almost moments in your career yeah yeah
yeah there's those things have happened
to me like what has happened that I
don't know yes there's the Paul
McCartney one good one you jam with Paul
McCartney this wasn't even a Jim I had
written some piano pieces that and he
was dabbling and writing like classical
style music right and I had some so it
was set up that he was gonna come to my
house he was out in the Hamptons I was
living in the hymns at the time he has a
place out there he stays there it's
right summer Paul McCarty's gonna come
over my house now I'd known Paul for
years but not really close just kind of
hi polite doing and you never were alone
with him in a room one-on-one yeah we
mean we talked but this was you know
this was like at a party or something
this is just gonna be me and him hanging
out and he's a hero to you he's the
reason you got into music yes right and
he's also someone you can respect how
many people can you respect as a
songwriter not too many I mean him and
John to me with the greatest songwriting
team of all time
I grew up there with Gilbert and
Sullivan I guess so he's gonna come on
my house gonna hear these pieces his
attorneys my attorney so he kind of got
together for him to come to my house
Paul McCartney's coming my house Wow
Paul look who's gonna be at my house
right so I what if he wants to know
something nice cold drink I'll have
something the fridge and I open the
fridge and I look at that fridge and
there's some cold cuts it's not good
enough there's well no it's not doubting
me he's not a meat guy he does and he's
like a d90 meat person of all tonight
right and I'm looking at my fridge and
I'm seeing you know like turkey breasts
and you know cold beef or something it's
starting to look like Jeffrey Dahmer's
refrigerator right I'm picking up all up
is the fridge he's gonna freak out he's
gonna run out of my house I'm gonna talk
to me it so I decide I'm gonna take all
the meat out of the refrigerator and put
it somewhere else
right literally I was gonna hide the
salami yeah I go through the fridge and
I'm pulling out this but when Ida and
I'm hiding it in drawers
really the house yeah house you cared
you didn't want him to be offended I
didn't want him to I don't bother him
but with my meat right right
meet well I had to put it somewhere he
was coming you know I'm looking at my
watch he's gonna be here any minute when
I put the mean I can't throw it in the
pantry I put it in the drawer and so we
had a nice date hanging out listening
talking about back that up for a second
when you say you had a nice day talking
about when he comes in are you nervous
not nervous just kind of excited awkward
silences no no I mean we've known each
other long enough to not have you know
jeez I betcha
Oh golly gee whiz he was a regular guy
he's a regular got very very nice man
good family man when you say good family
man don't you think his relationship
with Linda is everything a guy should
have a relationship with a woman they
had this mutual respect the whole thing
worked out he was madly in love with
that woman you see him with his family
say this is a real good family man
everybody loves everybody else to get
along even though they fight like
everybody you know Katzenberg but he's a
good - so you're sitting in there you're
talking with him you having a nice day
do you whip out the instruments and
they're in sort of a jam or a meeting of
the minds musically um wasn't so much
that we jam there was a piano in the
room but he was playing me some of his
tapes and I was playing him some of my
tapes and then to illustrate a point we
would go over to a piano see I was
thinking of this chord you know instead
of that chord and you know things like
that just like music musicians stuff run
our language and that went on for a few
hours then he left he never looked in
the fridge he never asked what was the
point of that musical conversation was
the were you feeling each other out to
say maybe we should make an album
together or a song together no wasn't
that so much I wanted to know what he
thought of the stuff I was writing and
he wanted to know what I thought of the
stuff he was writing right kind of a
mutual respect songwriter thing could
you criticize a song he's writing and
saying I don't think you have a right I
don't know if that's what he wanted I
probably wouldn't do that I wouldn't
have the audacity to tell Paul you'd say
hey consider this or did you ever
consider that kind of thing I don't even
know if I would do that I mean to me
he's like the master right so how do I
know better than him it's just that's my
taste well what an amazing day to sit
there and play with him I mean nothing
further ever came of it you guys never
got together again though we did we got
to get we got closer you know from
hanging out that day but the upshot of
this of this story is he leaves and I'm
like thrilled I'm calling everybody Hall
was at the house
we're talking music in the and then like
a few days go by and I'm looking around
what's that smell hahahaha that is like
dead chicken five days and I had to go
around the house and I couldn't find the
meat oh that's so well hidden it was
like a treasure hunt for your meat yeah